okay thanks um I thank the organizers
for giving me a chance to to talk about
this in this workshop here
so I I want presenter simple result
which is
different proof of pilot repetition in a
special case in the case of no signaling
games and the kind of multiplayer games
that we saw in an kits talk on Monday
but the technique that underlies the
proof is I think interesting and it's
based on the the class of theorems that
I would call it definitely theorems or
definitely reductions um that I'm
assuming maybe not everyone or most of
you are not familiar with so though I'm
hoping uh so because the talk will be in
two parts and first part will be
introducing these definitely theorems
what they are and what they say and
second part will be well how do you
apply these to do this on to this
particular case of repetition
so definitely theorems they're just
theorems about the structure of
distributions that are invariant under
permutations of the coordinates so you
fix a finite alphabet you can think of a
as just being zero one bit and then you
take a distribution on strings over that
alphabet and the assumption that we'll
all throughout the talk is that this
distribution is invariant under
permutations of the coordinates and the
question is what kind of interesting
things are can we say about such
distributions
so some examples are for instance if you
take a distribution that's just iid
copies of the same distribution then
this is permutation environment
that's not a knowing the only thing and
another example of a distribution thats
permutation variant if you take the
uniform distribution over n bit strings
that have exactly n over 2 1020 so
that's also permutation r and more
generally actually you can convince
yourself easily that any distribution
thats permutation invariant is going to
be a convex combination of distributions
that are uniform over all strings that
have a certain type we're in the case
where my alphabet is 0-1 the type is
just a number of ones if the alphabet is
bigger you just count the number of
times any symbol appears
so that's exactly the kind of
distributions we're looking at and
definitely a 60s Italian mathematician
showed the following so he showed that
if distribution P such as this one here
which is not only permutation invariant
but also it arises as the marginal of
the permutation invariant distribution P
hat on not only n but also n plus 1 of 2
and plus 3 etc all the way R to infinity
then your distribution you can write it
as a convex combination of iid
distributions
or
30s did I get this wrong
okay I don't know why I said 69 then is
there something in 69
all right so 30s even earlier than home
right so he was interested definitely I
think that there was there was there is
debates about you know beige anism and
frequent ism and he was interested in
selling that debate so a sort of a
foundational question whether you can
know in which cases can you legitimately
assign priors like when is it that they
existed and lying prior and so here
you're thinking of drawing random
variables you know drawing samples from
the sequence of random variables and
you're making the assumption that the
underlying distribution is permutation
invariant because these samples you
don't distinguish you know the first
sample from the second sample and then
under that assumption there exists a
underlying prior which is this this
measure DQ here that you can estimate
just by taking the limits of the
frequencies so it's it's it's a holy bit
and so um as far as I know then nothing
much happened on this and then be this
was picked up by
is just any samples from it's a convex
combination so it means that how do you
take a sample from p first you take our
distribution you take you choose a
distribution q just on a on the single
copy of the alphabet according to some
measure DQ so the statement is are there
exists a measure DQ on distributions on
a or such that p is a convex combination
according to that measure of iid onyx
combination of I how do you sample from
be of first
the only correlation is which
right right so it's they're definitely
not it right yeah so for instance you
could imagine that p is a example in bit
strings right is first you choose a bias
for the coin and then you flip iid coins
with that bias but the DQ would be the
measure under which you choose the bias
in the first place who's that
distribution is permutation environment
but it's not iid right if you do you
know if you choose either by a supporter
or three quarters for instance
no so I'm going to give you a hint about
the proof of something stronger aunt
than that I don't know definitely so I
don't think he proved that young people
didn't prove stuff in that so he
probably claimed it I don't know if
there might be a very easy pro you an
easy proof and there might be a
so the easy proof will be of a slightly
stronger statement which was so this was
picked up by diaconis and then there's a
paper by diaconis and friedman where
they asked arm well what can you do if
you don't make this assumption that you
know your representable as the marginal
of something like where r goes to
infinity forever er what if you fix and
you just know that p is the distribution
so b is my P hat over there so P is the
distribution on n plus our coordinates
and what I'm comparing is I take them I
marginalize over our of the coordinates
any are the last are because it's
permutation invariant and I look at the
resulting distribution on n coordinates
and I ask ok how close is that to a
convex combination of iid things in the
trace the total variation distance and
so what they showed is that this
distance is going to be at most maybe
look at the second term here it scales
like get rid of the N so it scales like
today get this wrong and
right you should see this as scaling
like n over R right so n is the number
of systems you keep number of
coordinates you keep and r is the n plus
R is the total that you had so if you
want this error to be small if you start
with something that has a 100
coordinates and you keep only 25 this
will be like a quarter
so this is the new move over cue the
right hand side you mean there exists
did I forget know there is a measure DQ
yeah so the best the best measure DQ
will do that yeah you can it's
constructive or you can you can define
on what is DQ oh it is not correct
no no so r goes to infinity here so you
think of our as being a large parameter
oh
I sorry I didn't quantify everything
this is for for any artists hold
yes yes so n is the number of
coordinates you're looking at it's this
distribution our pedis permutation over
environment but you're adding some extra
assumptions which is that it actually
arises as the marginal of something
that's permutation invariant on more
coordinates and bizarre
it's really an explanation for this
tutor yeah so i'm going to show you on
the next night so well to some extent
but i think you're going to see it i
can't see it exactly what it terms with
oh let me show you so that's the same
theorem here so let's do it for 44 bit
strings just because it's easier so we
already said this right so anything
that's permutation environment is going
to be a mixture of uniform over strings
that have 0 ones 1121 subset and there's
definitely such distributions are very
far from iid for instance if I take
myself to be uniform over strings that
have n plus R over 2 so half ones then
this is definitely not iid because it
has no variance at all in the numbers of
zeros and ones if I try to do this as
well you know coin flips I'm not going
to get there
so now but let's think of what so but
here I didn't marginalize anything right
so i have to marginalize over the air
our coordinates this is what's going to
save us so when we describe an
experiment um that's going to explain
what what's happening here and this is a
diagram this friedman on what they
should so what my initial distribution
this permutation invariant distribution
is i can think of it so let's just fix
this particular example when I have a
half ones so it's like being uniform
distribution over an urn that has half
white balls and half red balls right
half ones and half zeros and now what's
the distribution that's obtained by
marginalizing our coordinates it means I
only look at n coordinates so I take n
samples from this urn without
replacement and that's a sample from my
for my pee in this particular case right
I started from something uniform over
bit strings that have half ones and have
zeros this is this but now I take only n
samples because I marginalized the are
extra ones so this is what i have
now what's going what would something be
that saw iid well it would be almost the
same but some ID distribution would be
taking n balls from the urn but now with
replacement if i do that then all my
samples are independent i am putting it
back in this is just in that particular
case this would just be coin flips with
via so half that would be doing and so
the whole question is just uh what is
the difference between these two
distributions that's what we're trying
to measure as r goes to infinity and you
can imagine that as our is very large if
i take only a small and the number of
samples with or without replacement is
going to be the same right and so these
two distributions are the world the
distribution that you get with
replacement this is just burn ooey our
coin flips and the one we found
replacement this is the hyper geometric
distribution and so then it all boils
down to calculating the statistical I
mean don't the parameters are just what
they need to be the statistical distance
between these two distributions and you
see that it scales on like something
like this when the when their bit
strings larger alphabets you get
dependence on your for that size so you
can do an exact calculation and these
are these are the worst cases like what
store what's the worst distribution in
terms of far what's the worst p it's
this it's uniform over bit strings that
have
so it's a very nice
very nice very nice so I find it a very
nicely so so by taking a limit for art
sorry who was asking for proof for it oh
I hope you are asking so if you take R
to infinity you get a proof of though
the exact statement of course but maybe
there's a much easier proof in the case
where you know that our can be made
arbitrarily large
so for the application I have in mind to
pile repetition we're going to look at a
different formulation of this theorem
very similar and it's going to apply not
to just distribute Shinzon on bit
strings but what I call our systems so
families of distributions are going to
represent the strategies of the players
in these games so now I have two finite
sets my questions and my answers or my
inputs and outputs and what they look at
is these conditional distributions so
this is just notation for saying that I
have a family of distributions on this
set a parametrized by elements Q of my
set r cube and you can keep a B 0 1 and
Q B 0 1 foot for the whole top if you
want and so now the generalization of
the notion of being permutation
invariant I'll call it our n
exchangeable so it means that if you
permute the inputs according to some any
permutation and you permute the output
according to the simple mutation then
your whole family of distributions is
isn't changed
and
here's a different formulation of so
this is another type of definitely term
from which you can derive the one that I
was showing you before but that's the
one that's going to be more useful for
us so take any distribution like this
then again there is a measure DQ so the
differences are that here I'm not
marginalizing over anything right I'm
taking the original system here now I
don't have a bound on total variation
distance I have a upper bound so what
this means is that i think i have it
below i'm sorry so one way to parse this
is to say that for any event E and you
fix you can fix inputs here the
probability that this exchangeable
distribution the signs to the event E is
that most what the prefactor think of
this as being a constant times the
probability that the iid distribution
would assign to the same event in
particularly this event was a product
event here you'd have the probability of
the event under just one single
coordinate raised to the N so you'd have
and this pre factor here is you should
think of it as being polynomial in N and
then it has an exponential dependence on
the size of the of these sets and that
there's going to be an issue later on
but like I just want to think about
constant slightest sense if there is
more symmetries on your family you can
improve this constant a little bit but
that's not going to be relevant for the
talk and if you know that this was a
whole as I said it before by taking
marginalizing some coordinates you can
arrive at the bound very similar to the
total variation distance kind of bond
that we have in the previous slide but
I'm not she I've never seen this proven
anymore anyway it's a nice exercise
trying to show it this implies the other
formulation it's interesting yeah
all right so if a
so local symmetries so if for instance
or you'd have that the
you know that for some reason are the
distribution P is invariant under say
flipping the value of a1 right so it
assigns the same weight to the first bit
being 0 or the first plate being one so
some some inner symmetries inside a or
inside q that also give it invariant
then you can you know this here this is
basically the number of degrees of
freedom of just one system like Q times
a and if there's fewer degrees of
freedom you get a better little bit
it's very easy to prove this is counting
home
so before showing you briefly how this
can be able is this okay everyone can
pass this with this is the thing that
I'm going to use so a
and n qn doesn't need to be exchangeable
right otherwise it would be I think
those of this knitting know the Joint
Distribution no no right right right so
this is a more restricted I mean if you
thought of this as just a distribution
on you know a cross Q repeated n times
then it wouldn't be exchangeable across
yeah
so there's a few applications of this
there's there's many more applications
of this okay so little in in so the
original theorem it's been generalized
to Markov chains so where the assumption
of permutation variance is a bit weaker
it's a Markov chain like our kind of
assumption
being used to study graph but I don't
know much also there's some free
probability I don't know much about
these something may be closer is sodium
as a paper recently are very nice so
generalizing this motion so studying it
under weaker assumptions then the full
permutation invariants and so proving
results related to that and then they
have an application to analyzing
rounding algorithms so but aside from
that it hasn't been that much used in
the in theoretical computer science as
far as I know except in quantum
information weights it's a very
important result so there's
generalizations of this that apply not
to classical distribution but to quantum
states also saying that these quantum
states density matrices are invariant
under permutation of different systems
and the theorem in that case says that
those Clay's states are close to
separable it doesn't matter if you don't
understand that but it's used in many
different contexts for instance are
showing security of quantum key
distribution or showing that certain
methods are for performing tomography
are particularly efficient it also has
applications in Hamiltonian complexity
so there it takes on many many different
flavors that I'm not going to touch upon
so its move to applying this to the
setting of pal repetition now so they
let me just armed breathing we call it
the kind of games that we're thinking
about so same same kind as an kids talk
on on Monday there's going to be K
players think of K being two or three or
four that interact with the referee the
referee chooses a couple of questions
sense them to the players the players
provide answers and then the referee
decides to accept the answers or not now
depending on the questions and the
oldest information is public there's a
distribution on questions that I didn't
talk forward to write down
so what's the strategy for the players
in a multiplayer game in general is just
a function right from questions two
answers and to be fully general we think
of these players as acting jointly so
they have a joint strategy and this
joint strategy goes from you know the
whole couple of questions the whole k
topple of answers and so this is
described by a family of distributions
like this and so the game you can think
of it as acting as a linear function on
this set of strategies and so I define
the value of the game to be the maximum
success probability of any strategy in
the game this is just notation here what
do we have here supremum overall
strategies or allowed strategies this is
what my f will be of the average over
the choice of a random question
according to some distribution i sum
over all answers i count 0 or 1
depending of the answer was valid or not
and this is the probability of my
players actually giving me though the
corresponding answer
simple expression and so then you can
study this value under different
restrictions on the players the typical
restriction is that what i would call
the classical restrictions these players
are classical what kind of strategies
can classical players implement maybe
using shared randomness convex
combinations of product strategies right
so this is thinking each of them just
using a private coin and then if they
also have a public coin then you get the
convex hull of such color distributions
but you can look at other families of
players for instance quantum players the
kind of distributions that they can
implement would look like this doesn't
matter I'm just giving you the one that
I was going to look at in the talk or no
signaling strategies so this is sort of
important just the definition what's a
no singing strategy it's something that
my lie outside of this convex hull but
the restriction is that if you look at
the outputs are the answers you
marginalize on and you look only at the
outputs on the subset then this
distribution only depends on the
corresponding inputs all right so if I
look at only the answer is in the settee
but I change the inputs or the questions
outside of T so two other players then
the marginal distribution is though
isn't changed so that's mostly meaning
strategies
you a quick example arm so if you take
you know bits to players bits these are
my questions and answer sets let's take
the univ distribution that's uniform on
all pairs of bits a1 and a2 whose parity
is one if both questions were one and
whose parity parity is one of both
questions were one so they're different
and whose parity is zero in all other
cases then this is no signaling why is
it no signaling because the marginal
distribution on either side is uniform
um
you can check that because I'm always
taking the uniform distribution over all
pairs of bits that have a certain
priority and so the marginals our
uniforms is definitely no signaling but
you can't write it it doesn't fall in
this convex hull it doesn't even fall in
in this side so then you know there's
mostly new distributions that are not
classical O'Connor
all right and the question that we want
to study is that of parallel repetition
are we saw that on Monday how does the
value of the game repeated n times
relate to the value of the original game
and so here this you could say what is
the amortized value of the game under
pilot repetitions as the number of
repetition goes to infinity so I'm just
playing this game n times in parallel
and accepting the answers if and only if
they were correct in each each
repetition in each instance so
so I had a survey of more results but it
it doesn't maybe this doesn't really
matter too much now
because I don't have so much time so let
me just try to say a little bit how
you'd apply the definitely theorem to
study this question in the inner no
signal in case
alright so I mean the point is that why
would you hope that parallel reputation
holes this verifier you're running the
game these are n instances that are
played independently by the verifier so
what's important for that is then we'd
you know we'd like to claim that the
best that the players can do is also
play independently because of that so we
know that doesn't hold in general what
we do know though is because the referee
treats all these repetitions
independently we can assume that there's
some permutation invariance on the
strategy of the players because the
referee could you know permute the
questions I'd random get the answers
under the permutation the result would
be exactly the same so this is the one
element of structure that I have on the
strategies of players in a repeated game
is the only thing that I know it has
this permutation in balance and it is
good because this is exactly what we
want to be talking about um this is the
same expression for the value of the
game I rewrote the definite TTM there on
the top we want to be applying this this
is something that applies to permutation
invariant distributions we have a
permutation very distribution let's
apply it right so the value of the game
is a linear function of the distribution
all the coefficients are positive so the
inequality I can apply it it goes
through and I get this and now what did
i do here i use the fact that this
criterion for acceptance in the game the
repeater game is the product of
accepting you except here this is one if
any if you accept it everywhere so it's
the product of the things this once I've
upper bounded by this it's also a
product so what I get is this expression
there raised to the nth power
it is quite nice because now I recognize
here just the value of a single instance
of the game when the players would play
the certain strategy s here that's given
by my measure my sort of prior on
strategies for a single game and
so all right let's raise this to the
power 1 over n we get this constant to
the 1 over n so this is going to go to 1
as n goes to infinity and then this here
I can just take what's the worst case
right so I'll take the supremum overall
strategies in the support of my prior of
how well that strategy does and this
will be raised to the end when I raised
to the 1 over N i get the value of the
game so sort of proved pile repetition
for you I have that the amortized value
is at most you know something that goes
to 1 times a the best that the strategy
could do in the Indus again
so it's the issue here the issue is that
i don't have control over the support of
this prior distribution here so the know
this definitely theorem is saying that
there's a prior this prior is a prior
over strategies for the single game but
what kind of strategies are these
classical strategies quantum strategies
no signaling strategies I don't know
could be anything could be it is just a
function from tuples of inputs to top
toppers of outputs if you want to
implement it think of it as the strategy
it might require a lot of communication
and it's easy to see that this can
happen in general you can have a very
nice distribution that's no signaling
anything you want forces the uniform
distribution and you can write it as a
convex combination of things that are
very wild right and so here I'm taking
the supremum over very wild things of
how well they can do in my game so this
could be just one and then I haven't
achieved anything
so this is why you sort of one who
applied that theorem but it's not
trivial are to apply it and I should say
that actually we you know we have
counter examples too strong probably
reputation or certain ranges of
parameters that show you that you can't
just hope this outline to go through on
just like this and
I should how much time do I have five
min four minutes okay
so then the work is to go around this
and this is what we did in the no signal
in case and I don't know how to do in
the classical case so I guess I get to
say a few words about this so the point
is now we have additional structure on
this s there's this no signaling our
condition and we want to find a way to
say that such a condition should hold
also on these
strategies as that show up in the
support of my prior or at least in those
that show up with non-negligible
probability
and so the other end of the argument is
this well it's suppose that we start
with something honest so no sling
strategy for the players and we'd like
to argue that this measure here doesn't
place too much mass not much more we're
shooting for exponential decay in this
success probability so we're shooting
for really small mass on things that we
can't control we cannot control and
reasoning is by contradiction suppose
and suppose for simplicity here let's
assume this was an equality right so
suppose i wrote my no signaling thing as
a convex combination of things that are
iid but some of them might involve
signaling they're not strategies that
one I want to rule that out I'm gonna
say there should be few of those and so
the argument will say well if there's
really a good chance or you know a
non-negligible chance for this prior to
be signaling then this thing here should
be signaling and that will use the fact
that i have an iid copies so it's it's
sort of silly yeah
and so the idea is to say to try to
implement this is to say that
suppose this was the case and
suppose I was to give this the ways
possibility for players to sample text
use this distribution as some guy to be
distributed our resource then they could
signal using this and then we contradict
the assumption that it's no signaling
and how would they signal the idea is
that
maybe i don't know if it's so useful to
be but i will a good here um the idea
would be just just just look at this um
you get a sample from this right so
which means first you choose a sample s
from the prior and then you get many iid
copies and you know that there's a small
because we're reasoning by contradiction
you know that there's a small chance
that the prior selected some
distribution that was signaling and so
what you can do is you can try to
observe do some kind of tomography do
some statistics on a subset of the
coordinates using that determined what
kind of distribution did you have if
it's not the signaling distribution and
you sort of ignore it do nothing but if
it is signaling then you can use the
remaining coordinates and the sort of
signaling power that you have in these
remaining coordinates in order to
signal so in order to exchange
information between the different
players in the and this will contradict
the original assumption
and the difficulty in doing this is and
this is why we can work it out in the no
signaling case and not in the classical
case is how do you estimate this
distribution
the that you're you know which element
of the prior the iid samples that you
get from was given to you because you
need to do that as separate isolated
players and so if you're just trying to
distinguish whether you got whether the
prior is selected something that was
signaling or not then this is easy to do
locally without any communication
but detecting whether you were given
something that's classical or not
quantum or not this is not something
that I know how to implement locally and
this is why though thing would not
extend it I'm going a little bit fast
because I'm out of time I think I should
this was a little bit more details how
this is done but I guess I just gave you
the the Tom outline this is a repetition
of the outline or maybe I just stayed to
result in either end are here here's the
result and there's some I just want to
point out you know the kind of
advantages and drawbacks it might have
an important advantage is that it
extends almost as is to any number of
players number of players is not so much
important here in the news link case and
having parallel repetition for games
with more than two players in the
classical or quantum case this is a
challenge so this might give you some
idea that this could be interesting
another interesting thing about it is
that it very easily gives you threshold
or theorems instead of just parallel
reputation just by the exact same
arguments and it gives you a threshold
theorem with optimal sort of
concentration around the expected number
of repetitions that you should satisfy
the bad thing about the result is is
this prefactor arm and in particular the
fact that you know this is polynomial in
the number of repetitions but there was
this exponential dependence on the
number of questions and answers and this
is really due to the definitely and also
this method of doing statistics
estimating what element you got from the
prior if you want to be do able to do
that reliably you need at least as many
samples as the support of your
distribution and that's the number of
questions and answers so it seems that
this kind of approach is limited to
having very the exponential dependence
on on these question and answer sets
which means is not going to be useful
for instance for hardness amplification
or such things there's advantages it has
drawbacks and I'm
over time I apologize for that um let's
stop here
question or the next ketosis
so for the cake layers face saying that
is over a complete yeah yeah so that
it's very interesting but no signaling
strategies that do not have complete
support are very strange in particular
you can have something that it depends
it actually it ends up depending how you
define non signaling so you can have
strategies that a sort of distributions
are non signaling for the questions on
which they're defined
but but it's impossible to extend them
to something that's globally non
signaling and that creates a problem
it's related to the parameters so if you
you know you need to do all these up to
some air and then you need to say what's
something that's approximately signaling
and say that something that's
only that's close to non signaling is
going to not have too much larger value
in the game then something that's
exactly signaling and that that's where
things start breaking down if you don't
[Applause]